it was one of those rare things where
you're shooting 6 days a week and then
you rap and then everyone would want to
go out to there was a bar that was the
Tarantino theme bar it was about the
size of this table first night we're all
like Panorama out some really cool place
and then someone's like you know Quenton
they named the bar after you and so
we're like what we go there and it's
it's up to death proof is as far as it
gotten so there's drink called the
rubber duck and there's like Death Proof
stuff and Grindhouse and fall fiction
and a qu but the bar is like literally
half the size of this room so all of us
and they're they're smoking were they
their mind blown when you guys walked in
there I mean I'm sure no they went in
and they were like welcome home what do
you want like they they they were so
cool about it welcome home they were
like cuz they knew we were in town
shooting they're like Quenton this is
your living room this is your house
anything you need we're here for you and
quent's like so so you could tell like
every night like the cast would come to
me and they're like they're like Eli
please there's a very cool bar they want
to have this like a very VIP for us with
bottle service and blah blah blah but
Quenton doesn't want to go there I think
he's going to want to go back to
Tarantino bar so like at rap everyone
everyone would be like they're like you
know we'd rap at like 11:00 on after a
six day week and we're shooting and
we're going to go out and quent's like
why don't we just why don't we and I'm
be like Tarantino Mar he's like yeah and
then they be like Eli what are you doing
and qu's like rubber duck shots for
everyone it was so so fun man wow and
then there you know there's always that
moment in a movie where you're like
halfway through the shoot and it's like
it's sort of becomes the deao rap party
it's like the rap party everyone's kind
of tired people leave but like there's
this point where you like break at the
Midway of a shoot and there's just one
night where it just spirals out of
control and they were shooting the scene
with a telephone at the ending with BJ
Novak and Brad and everyone's about to
break for Christmas and they were in
this old German dance hall and we
wrapped and like Brad stayed in his
tuxedo and everyone just stayed in there
like Brad said Brad's in this cool tux
so he just like stayed in his tux and we
all just like hung out and got he didn't
take the makeup or [__] off and he just
cuz he just looked so cool and everyone
was like dressed in their 30s clothes oh
my God you know they took the swas [__]
off of course but then then there was a
moment I'll tell you this this is Brad
there's a moment at the can film
festival where they really like separate
you know we're in the trenches we're all
together when you get to the C Film
Festival they like okay these are the
four leads this is the blah blah blah
and the guards on the thing and the
publicists are like no it's this is just
Brad and Quenton and Michael fast bender
and Eli and Dian Krueger and Mel and
we're all like you know kind of like
taking the steps and we're doing the
photos and Daniel Brule and then Brad
stops the red carpet like he puts his
hands up and just everyone just stops
and he walks back to the guards and he
says excuse me and he parted them and he
brought everybody everybody that had got
on a plane that had anything no matter
how minor in the movie he brought them
on the red carpet with all of us it was
the most Aldo it was the coolest movie
star move and that was it and like
Angelina they were together at the time
so it was just like this guy is such a
class Angelina yeah remember her they
were
married yeah yeah yeah she was there jly
angel angel hi I'm Bobby Lee I'm here to
audition you before is Angel Jolly in
this whose mouth do I [__] in I'm ready
I got to go quick hurry sorry um yeah so
but it was like that that's what it was
like so from the moment we landed on the
plane to that moment at the can film
festival of Brad like parting the Red
Sea to bring everyone along you're like
yeah that that was the spirit of that
movie okay beautiful and then to see
people around the world respond to it
and to see it resonate today people like
you know it's an iconic inspirational
character that was like one of the
greatest you know periods of my life
doing that yeah it's just that movie was
just had an imprint on me too yeah
watching it it was just like I mean I
just think that he's just one of the
greatest yeah he well yeah there's just
no one at his intellectual level
cinematic level with a real
understanding and sensitivity in
humanity that I don't think he gets
credited for because his movies are so